almost all of us have to pay council tax
but the amount varies massively
depending on where you live
Hannah Lucy and Zoe are in okem which
under Rutland Council has the highest
rates in the country
do you guys feel like you're getting
value for money from that that's true no
I think it's it's
a point where we're seeing
development in the town but also an
actual reduction in the infrastructure
and in the facilities is stripping back
so we're paying more and more and more
and getting less and less and less it's
just making an already unaffordable
situation harder yeah you know you're
already
um trying not to turn your heating on as
much as possible to save those few extra
pennies and now there's a few extra
pennies are going to go into the
council's pocket
people pay council tax based on the type
of property they live in calculated all
the way back in 1991 and the value it
was then
it's tough for people like Lucy Zoe and
Hannah in Rutland they live in an area
with the highest council tax in the
whole of the country and over 2 400
pounds Nottingham Lewis Dorset and
Wilden not far behind all in the top
pairs of tax
by comparison three of the lowest paying
places are in London if you live in a
band D property in Westminster you're
only paying 883 pounds for the privilege
when we look at proportion of income
people in Mole Valley Council area are
paying over eight percent of their
income on council tax but at the other
end of the scale in Southwest London
Wandsworth people are paying just 2.1
percent
council tax is the definition of a
postcode Lottery houses here in
Wandsworth can cost millions of pounds
but people are spending a lower
proportion of their income than people
in poorer areas and there's plenty more
inconsistency across the system
back in okum and it also looks well to
do but Rutland Council says that masks
some deprived areas and argues they
receive much less funding from central
government per household than other
places there is a fundamental message
around fairness to 504 pounds compared
to 1019 pounds really simply isn't fair
and that's all we're asking for a little
bit bit more money to be fair
over the coming weeks Sky News will be
looking at which councils are failing
and how that affects the services we all
depend on wherever we live Tom Cheshire
Sky News Oakham Rutland